[Music]
hello to all I'm a girl come to an end
so the president of simbock d'industrie
we are a Toulouse sme about
twenty people and we are developing
voice assistants for the
industrial sector in particular to assist
field operators in their
production maintenance quality control
logistics tasks so we are at the
crossroads between two worlds which are on the one
hand based systems there is since
in the voice assistant must find
different
voice recognition voice synthesis bricks of the  elected
from agendia the smell
of knowledge base database and then the world
of industry 4.0 and in particular
the operator connected or increase and
here we are I would say at the intersection
of these two of these demands which
make sparks we're going to say it like that
what we bring to the project
contains fruit from people we are very proud of
course to be the winner
the idea was to see how our
interface  this conversational can deal
with two problems the first for the
problems it is the invention of explaining
ability in particular on
field operators they are companions
of the workers
they are not engineers here and that
is our world knows  that all our
systems today are deployed
in large industrial companies where
you have operators here at
different levels so it is a
problem that has in fact been concrete
for several years with the caps
that you see at the top right which is
camped in Toulouse which  is going to be a partner
on the project a week ago that is
waiting for the
humanities and social sciences laboratory and then he gave
the second subject it was the validation
of the results of the ai and in the corner this
conversational interface can assist
the operator in  this validation this
non-validation of
which three co-founders
started in 2013 so we are a
start-up and today our
systems are deployed in  s different
fields
of nuclear energy building
space guarantee each time there is an
operator technicians on the ground
in Arles to interest us and we
really try to do this syria of the workshop
where the year included or  Opposite here
it's people like ebay watson it
's people like them like microsoft
cortana rather big players and we
try to bring this
French solution 100% I have news from the scpri
thank you very much
thank you philippe
[Applause]
[Music  ]